you're the voice of the mom in boss baby
oh yeah and it's got an Oscar nomination
what is that does that mean that you go
to the Oscars
I don't think so right just cuz I mean
you're a pretty prominent voice you're
the mom and so that would think I would
think you could go to the Oscars if you
wanted yeah I mean I could buy a ticket
yeah just your voice gets to go yeah
yeah but you don't think you're good do
you like award shows well who doesn't
like it requires any effort yeah to
prepare to go yeah yeah woman yeah no
easy just no route this on and I mean
this is how I look every day yeah I can
test that I see you often you always
look beautiful it is a little unfair
women have to spend you know it's really
close man when I've got your wart shows
my wife will hole up in a part of the
house and I hear drilling and sawing and
riveting and there and then she come and
I just put on you literally just put on
a tuxedo and you go so you know it is
unfair it's unfair it's wrong
good I stood up for women that's my big
thing
I think that's all it to be really all
about
you